[Music]
foreign
okay we are in the fourth lecture in our
series on complex analysis complex
variables complex functions and today
I'm going to introduce one of the most
important uh complex functions the
complex logarithm
so I'm going to be very specific that
this is the complex logarithm because it
is actually different than the real
value logarithm
and this is where we're going to start
seeing how strange things can be in the
complex function the complex plane so
the logarithm we found that the complex
exponential function was essentially
very similar to the the real valued
exponential it had a convergent Taylor
series it was analytic everywhere I
haven't told you exactly what analytic
means but it means that it has a
convergent Taylor series everywhere the
complex logarithm is a little bit more
complex of a creature
and uh yeah so this whole lecture is
going to be all about this function how
to derive it what are its properties and
I'll give you some hint about how we're
going to use it in the future uh so kind
of maybe I'll give away some of the the
punch line This is actually going to be
a function that has infinitely many
values for a given input Z there are
infinitely many complex logarithms of Z
and the fact that there this is an
infinite valued function it's going to
be that's a very important property when
we later use this for things like the
inverse Laplace transform or taking the
square root of negative I things that we
haven't done yet that we will do in
future lectures now that was too much
teaser I'm just going to Jump Right In
so the complex logarithm and I'm going
to use two different colors here I hope
so we're going to
um
we're going to let Z
equals X Plus i y this is our our input
variable
and we're going to let our output
variable W equal
U plus I V
okay and we're going to say essentially
that
um
w
is going to equal the logarithm
of my
Z variable here okay so we're going to
take the logarithm of Z and the output
of that logarithm is going to be this W
variable and we're specifically going to
Define this complex logarithm so that it
is the inverse of the complex
exponential so if this is true
then we expect
that the exponential of w is going to
equal Z so Z
should equal the complex exponential e
to the power
w
and so we're going to use this kind of
remember the logarithm and the
exponential are inverse functions of
each other for real valued arguments and
so for complex valued arguments we are
also going to expect that these are are
inverse as well so this is called an
inverse pair
and this is really common right like
multiplication and division are an
inverse pair addition and subtraction
are an inverse pair the Fourier
transform and the inverse Fourier
transform are an inverse pair log and
exponential are an inverse pair and so
we're going to use this to derive what
we mean by the logarithm of Z and
specific specifically
notice that I'm using a capital l
logarithm this is a very subtle thing
that uh you know mathematicians do to
specify that we're talking about logs of
a complex variable Z that's the capital
log logarithm the kind of complex
logarithm
good so I'm going to use this
relationship to derive what we mean by
log of Z in particular how do u and v
depend on X and Y and vice versa and
then we're going to derive some
interesting properties about these weird
functions u and v which are the
logarithm of Z
good
a little bit between this
Cartesian representation in terms of the
real and the imaginary part and also in
terms of the Polar representation in
terms of r e to the I Theta r e to the I
Theta okay so this uh sometimes it's
going to be easier to think about it in
terms of of this expression here
essentially have that Z
equal U
maybe I'll just stick with pink here so
this equals e
to the
U plus IV
and remember whenever you have e to the
a plus b it's e to the a times e to the
B
so this equals e to the U times e to the
IV that's e to the U times e to the i v
and remember U is real and V is also
real U is real and IV is imaginary so e
to the U this is a real valued
exponential this is a real number and e
to the IV that's just cos V plus I sine
V okay so we're going to use that
we're going to use that now so this
equals
let's say e to the U power I should just
keep this on hand
times
we're going to say this is uh
cosine of V plus I sine
of
V
good this is all you know essentially
just from this definition that the
logarithm has to be the inverse of the
exponential so I took my Z and W my and
I just flipped them and now I'm solving
for what are my Z terms in terms of my
my w terms
uh and here you know this is actually
where I could probably much more easily
just use the fact that
if I represent this
um you know in terms of the Polar
coordinates of z are e to the I Theta
it's pretty clear that R equals e to the
U
and Theta
equals V that's you know pretty obvious
that the only way that these can equal
each other this is a real number e to
the U has to equal R and E to the IV has
to equal e to the I Theta so that's
certainly uh certainly true here
and so I think I'm actually just going
to write down this answer I'm just going
to say you
equals or e to the U equals R so U has
to equal the logarithm
of r
and notice I'm using lowercase L
logarithm here because R is a real
number it's not a complex number R is a
radius it's a real number this is a real
valued logarithm and this U term here is
just the real valued logarithm of the
radius of Z
okay so log of Z the real part of that
is going to be the log of the radius of
Z
and the the imaginary part here V
equals Theta V equals Theta okay so
that's like uh pretty easy actually
we've we've essentially just shown that
for these two to the inverses of each
other you
the real part of my my log of Z has to
equal log of the radius of Z
and V the imaginary part of my log of Z
has to be the phase angle of my variable
Z this is certainly true
uh and I'm going to maybe write these
down
um
using an alternative notation that
you're very frequently going to see so
the this is also the log
of the norm or the absolute value of Z
so remember the absolute value of Z is
its length or its radius R that's just
this is just notation this is
definitional that Norm of Z equals R
okay literally if you took x squared
plus y squared it would equal r squared
that's what I mean by the length of that
Z
and similarly oftentimes Theta is
defined I'm just going to say defined as
the phase angle the angle of that
variable Z okay so literally if I was in
the complex plane this Z would have a
radius and the phase angle of Z equals
Theta so R equals the norm of Z theta
equals the phase ankle of Z but this is
essentially true this is absolutely true
for u and v
u and v equal these quantities in terms
of my original variable Z that I'm
taking the logarithm of
this is where it gets super weird okay
what's super weird
add
let me pick a color I could add
plus 2 pi n
here and nothing would change
because if I take my my variable Z that
is at an angle Theta and I add another 2
pi to it I'm right back where I started
cosine of theta plus 2 pi is equal to
cosine of theta sine of theta plus 2 pi
is equal to sine of theta and I can do
that for any whole number n of rotations
around in this complex plane so that's
really really interesting is that when I
take the logarithm of Z
this W quantity has to be the inverse
when I when I exponentiate W I need to
get Z back
and for any
of these I should be more careful if I
add plus 2 pi n here
if I add 2 pi n to this Theta when I
exponentiate that when I take you know
uh and I plug that into here for the V
it'll loop back around and it'll give me
r e to the I Theta these are going to be
equal quantities I could say this 10
more times more slowly what I'm going to
do is I'm going to draw you a picture
because it's going to make all the sense
in the world when I actually draw you a
picture of this but what this means
morally
is that for a single number Z for a
number Z which is
defined as you know r e to the I Theta
there are actually infinitely many
solutions to the complex logarithm of
that Z so this is true
for all
integer
n n could equal one two three four it
could equal negative one negative two
negative three negative four what that
means is that the same if I take this
the Z and I add 2 pi or 4 Pi or 6 Pi or
8 Pi or if I subtract 2 pi or 4 pi and
so on and so forth I get the same number
afterwards that that's what we're seeing
here is this kind of uh because you can
think of theta as rotating in the
complex plane when I add integers of 2
pi to that phase angle I get back right
where I started
uh okay good so I'm gonna draw you a
picture and then I'm going to write down
what this logarithm uh is so let's pick
and again I'm going to do this color
coded so I'm going to have two different
complex planes
this is kind of my input complex planes
where this is C uh this is the real you
know X and this is an imaginary y
and then once we take the logarithm
we're going to uh this is let's say my
my Z my Z
plane
my Z plane
and then here we're going to be talking
about the w
plane where similarly the imaginary part
is V and the real part is U and again
this is a complex plane and what we're
going to be doing is we're going to be
saying that you know if I go from Z to W
that's the log function takes me from Z
to w
and the exponential function the
exponential function e
to the W equals z and log of Z equals W
so w equals log of z z equals e to the W
and essentially what this function log
and E do is it Max me from the Z plane
to the W plane and back and forth okay
and so I'm going to draw my Z Vector in
my Z plane and I'm going to draw my w
Vector in my w plane and we're going to
understand kind of pictorially what this
relationship means and what it means for
this to be multi-valued
so in the Z plane I have my uh you know
my Z here
and this has a a radius and a Theta and
I think what I'm going to do is I'm
actually going to call this the
principal Theta this is Theta
p
because for any number Z that you pick
any point in this plane any X and Y
that Z could be defined as r e to the I
Theta p
but I could also add 2 pi or 4 Pi or 6
Pi or 8 pi and those are all equal to
the exact same point Z because if I go
around 2 pi I come back to the same
place if I go around 4 Pi I come back to
the same place so technically this could
be you know plus 2 pi N I could go
around 2 pi any integer number of times
and I'm still at exactly that point Z so
there are infinitely many angles I can
use to represent that angle of Z
and the the principal one is usually
defined to be between zero and two Pi so
this is a number between 0 and 2 pi and
of course I can add 2 pi as many times
as I like and I get back to the same
point
now the complex logarithm we know
that the real part of my complex
logarithm the U part so let's say uh the
uh the real part here the the real part
of w equals U and that equals
log of my radius so this is log of the
radius so this is a line which is
literally
the real part of w is log of radius log
of this radius
and the phase angle of of w could be any
one of infinitely many values it could
be Theta P so this point here is Theta p
but it could also be Theta p
plus 2 pi that is equally valid that's
also Z it could be Theta p
uh plus 4 Pi Theta P plus 4 pi and Theta
P plus 6 pi plus 8 pi plus 10 PI 12 and
so on and so forth minus 2 pi minus 4 Pi
so there are infinitely many points in
this W plane that when I exponentiate
them when I take e to all of these blue
dots when I take e to any of those it'll
map me exactly to this value Z okay so
that's really interesting the log of
this point Z has infinitely many values
that are all equally valid
and so I think what I want to do is I
want to write down the actual formula
here so uh the complex logarithm of Z
Capital log of Z equals a real part and
that real part is uh log of the radius R
which I'm going to say is log of you
know the length of Z
Plus
I times this principal angle the the
angle between 0 and 2 pi that uniquely
identify as that point Z
plus any integer multiple of 2 pi n this
is 4
all integer
n this is how the complex logarithm
is defined
and this is really really important so
the complex logarithm is an infinitely
Val an infinite valued function for
every Point Z there are infinitely many
logarithms of Z
if I choose n equals 0 this is called
the principal logarithm that's kind of
the standard logarithm okay and this
might seem weird but that's not the the
weirdest thing you've ever seen in math
remember if I take the square root of 9
that's also a multi-valued function we
know that there are two values for the
square root of nine three and negative
3. there are you know two values for the
square root of negative one I and minus
I this is no different there are just
infinitely many solutions of logarithm Z
for every integer power for every
integer n here and a teaser we're
actually going to use this formula to
compute things like the you know square
root of negative i what does that equal
to we're going to use this formula to
compute the square root of negative I or
we could compute the cubed root of
positive i what does that equal and I
claim that the square root is going to
have two solutions the cubed root is
going to have three solutions and so on
and so forth you can take things like
the pyth root of I that's going to have
infinitely many solutions just like the
complex logarithm so those are things
I'm going to show you in the next
lecture but it's not that weird that you
have a function with infinitely many
values we already are used to
multi-valued functions like the square
root of 9 has two values that are
equally valid here
good okay so I want to uh recap a little
bit because I think that this can be
confusing and I just want now that
you've seen it all
I'm going to slow down for a minute and
we're just going to go through the key
steps so that you can see where where
this idea of multi-value logarithm comes
from okay
so we are
logarithm of a complex input Z we're
calling it w that's the log of Z and we
expect that the log of Z is the inverse
of the exponential function so if if if
W is the log of Z then e to the W has to
equal Z
and if I take e to this all really
relies on the fact that if I take e to
the W
e to the W plus 2 pi I
is equal to you know basically I'm just
saying that's equal to e to the W I'll
come back to this in a minute
in terms of its real and imaginary part
and we expand Z in terms of its radius
and phase angle and through some you
know algebra essentially just just
plugging things in we find that U has to
equal the radius and V has to equal the
phase angle Theta okay that's that's a
that's a very valid Solution that's the
principal solution
but what we also find is that if we add
2 pi to this W it is still a solution uh
e to the W equals z that's still the
inverse of the logarithm and that's true
for 2 pi i 4 Pi I 6 Pi I 8 pi and so on
and so forth for all integer multiples
of 2 pi I that I could add to this thing
and why is that the case that is the
case because if I add 2 pi to this Theta
this cosine Theta and sine Theta don't
change because if I Define Z as r e to
the I Theta I could equally well Define
it as r e to the I Theta plus 2 pi plus
4 pi plus 6 Pi okay so that's why this
complex logarithm is multi-valued it's
because I can rotate this around any
multiple of 2 pi and I have the same
value Z
this is going to really require you to
sit quietly and think about why this is
true and how this is true I think this
picture really helps me think about it
but this is one of the most fundamental
you know properties in complex analysis
is that some functions are multi-valued
like the square root function has two
values the cube root function has three
values the logarithm has infinitely many
values good
uh and so there is this notion of of
something called a branch cut in complex
analysis I'm just going to write this
down a branch
so essentially a branch
of a multi-value function
like the logarithm a multi-valued
function
f
of Z remember F of Z my my logarithm of
Z is multi-valued it has all of these
values a branch of a multi-valued
function Z is essentially is a single
valued function we'll call it f of Z
which is essentially
on a region
I'm going to use some math speak a
region D which is a subset of the
complex plane
that essentially coincides that is the
same as F of Z on that branch that I'm
going to draw you a picture that
coincides
with f of Z
on that branch
so let me draw you a picture because
this is a little bit confusing so the
the U component of log of Z is single
valued there is only one number for the
log of that radius and that never
changes I can't add 2 pi to that I can't
change that the the real part U is is
single valued it's the the imaginary
part the V component of w that's
multi-valued
and so if I take and I literally plot
this function there's kind of a cool way
you can plot this where you know this is
this is X and this is why this is the
the real valued part of Z and this is
the uh imaginary valued part of Z and I
plot
the imaginary part
of
log of Z
so kind of you know this equals V right
this is the V part of this the imaginary
part of my logarithm of x
what we find
is that this thing starts off
uh you know and you know at some value
let's say it starts off at zero
and as I go around in this complex plane
as I as I as I clock this thing around 2
pi 4 Pi 6 Pi 8 pi
this essentially winds up almost like a
spiral staircase in uh
uh in this this phase angle so this is
kind of a weird picture but what this
means is that if I take
my my complex plane here and I go around
in one Circle I go around in one Circle
I add 2 pi to this principal angle I
have added 2 pi so if I go around one
Circle in the in the X Y the Z plane
then I have essentially added
2 pi I to the phase angle of v and if I
go around a second time 4 Pi then I go
around and I've added another you know
this is plus another 2 pi so this is you
know another 2 pi I and each of these
levels of this kind of spiral staircase
of V is called a branch this is the
principal Branch but there are other
branches I could take of this
multi-valued function and generally
speaking we have some rules like we
would pick the principal Branch to be
the one between like minus pi and Pi or
0 to 2 pi just like you know when you
define a number in polar coordinates you
decide to find its principal Theta as
the Theta between either negative pi and
Pi or 0 and 2 pi it's exactly the same
thing here
uh and and this is really really weird
because if I do the following
I'm just gonna I'm gonna give you the
punch line because I can't help it this
is like where this is all going
is that if I take my you know my Z plane
and I
integrate
around a closed loop let's call this a
contour C if I integrate around a closed
Contour C that includes the origin
of log of Z DZ this is going to equal 2
pi I if I go around in a full circle if
I start here and I go around a full
circle of Z I have added 2 pi I of phase
to the logarithm of Z and so the
integral of that over that closed
circuit equals 2 pi I
this is the basis
of one of the most important integral
theorems in all of mathematics called
the koshy integral formula this is how
we're going to solve for the inverse
Laplace transform it's a super super
useful property that with these
multi-valued functions if I integrate a
closed orbit
and kind of go up one of these branches
I will add a phase angle of 2 pi I uh
through through that integral so this is
a really important property I'm going to
talk a lot more about what these complex
integrals in the complex plane mean so
if this if this was you know a little
confusing I'm going to have whole
lectures on what it means to integrate
in the complex plane around these closed
orbits but I just want to point out that
that the fact that this is a
multi-valued function means that if I go
around in a circle I add 2 pi I to my
phase angle if I go around in another
Circle I add another 2 pi I so I'm up to
4 pi and I can keep doing that if I keep
integrating around these closed orbits
okay so complex logarithm very very
important and special function it is the
inverse of the complex exponential and
because of the way that we Define these
complex variables in polar coordinates
where I can add 2 pi 4 Pi 6 Pi 8 pi and
so on to the angle this logarithm is
infinite valued we're going to use this
for things like the inverse Laplace
transform we're going to use this to
Define things like the square root of
negative I and the cubed root of I and
things like that so that's all coming up
stay tuned thank you